[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday March 31st I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
the Pentagon is gearing up for a future
conflict that doesn't take place on land
or sea but in space it comes as China
and Russia deploy missiles and lasers
that can take out satellites and disrupt
military and civilian Communications
joining me to discuss how the U.S
military is preparing for potential
threats is our Aerospace and defense
industry reporter Doug Cameron hi Doug
thanks for joining us good to talk with
you Zoe when we talk about armed
conflict in space I'm sure a lot of
people are imagining you know Star Wars
or Star Trek or any number of other
sci-fi films is the Pentagon planning on
having potential dog fights in
spacecrafts there's two big differences
between what you see in the movies and
what's reality first any potential
conflict in space is not going to
involve people there's not going to be
crude Fighters running around in space
it just doesn't work like that secondly
you just can't sneak up on people you're
traveling so fast the physics orbital
Mechanics for the the physics Majors you
just can't do that so no no dog fights
in terms of people chasing each other at
Close Quarters you have to kind of be
sneaky you have to plan it takes a lot
of fuel a lot of time to get one
satellite with no crew close to another
satellite with no crew so that's the big
difference between reality in the movies
and what is it particularly about space
and the you know environment in space
that means you can't use the same
military tactics or technology that you
might use on the ground so we go back to
the physics again just the simple speed
uh you know for the sake of your
argument your best fighter jet might go
at twice the speed of sound now with a
satellite just a regular orbits or near
Earth orbit you're talking about
something going at 17 000 miles an hour
so the time to affect is much limited
and one what that does in space it gives
the advantage if you think of being on
the ground in a trench you can't dig
trenches in space so just from a tactics
point of view that the attacker has the
advantage because wherever they're going
to come at you they're going to come at
you with great speed so that is probably
the big big difference attackers have
the advantage so tell us a little bit
about the U.S military's plan what
Ranch for instance is dealing with this
well this is all down to the space force
which was established in 2019 and we
talked about as a way to kind of focus
attention on the developing threats in
space so it was carved out of the Air
Force the idea would being that it would
provide services for all branches of the
military not just the Air Force and
would also just help Focus attention on
its core Mission which is both to deter
and to provide continued access in space
so all through the space force now
because of the threat environment
changing they now feel that they need to
train people in a different way although
it's difficult to attack people and it's
difficult to defend things in space you
still need to learn how to do it so what
they're going to do is to invest in
simulators just think of it like an
aircraft simulator in some way it's much
cheaper to train on that than to uh to
train on the limited amount of
satellites that are up there already
doing operations so that's what they're
going to do they're going to have
simulators they're going to to develop
basically tactics and you know try and
second guess through War Games what
adversaries might do and how you might
you might try to defeat or avoid them
it's very much a learning process and
it's very much at its infancy what kind
of funding are they getting to do this
well the space force has got a big old
budget now the request this year is is
something like 30 billion dollars now
remember that sort of 800 billion for
the US military as a whole that's up far
more percentage-wise than other services
now within that the extra training
budget they're talking about is 400
million still a lot of money but
compared to the hardware to launch the
rockets and build the Rockets which is
the bulk of the the 30 billion it's
still relatively small potatoes which
just gives you an idea that they're at
the start of a process and yep there's a
long way to go what you can expect is
that budget is going to continue to
increase as the years class can you
describe the kinds of weapons they're
developing to engage in a possible
military conflict in space two simple uh
subsets you know things that go bang and
things that don't go bang in terms of
things that go bang you can talk about
potentially lasers in space which can
blind or disable another spacecraft this
work that's been going on where a
satellite can have like an arm or a
grappling hook which in theory could go
up to another satellite and pull it out
of orbit so these are what they would
call Kinetic capabilities and you could
add to that missiles which are actually
shot from the ground to to blow up a
satellite Russia did that in a test on
one of its own satellites some years ago
the problem with that is it creates a
whole lot of space debris which is a
challenge for everybody because
everybody has to orbit in the the same
space the non-kinetic ones is it's
jamming and cyber warfare where you
basically interfering with the the
signals between space and the ground
isn't there a treaty on not engaging in
military conflict in space
there are many treaties most of which
have not been signed the main known
signatories tend to be those Nations
where with the biggest Assets in space
including the US so while there is a
kind of broad agreement at the highest
level not to militarized space everybody
is no one's actually signed on in a
clear-cut way saying we're not going to
do this it's more it's in the Vegas
terms because there is a land grab in
space Sounds a strange thing to say and
because it's such a fast-moving
technology no one kind of wants to rule
out anything because that might give
them the advantage in things like
resources on the moon or mining
asteroids down the line so everybody
amongst the big space-faring Nations has
basically kept their options open all
right that's wsj Aerospace and defense
industry reporter Doug Cameron thanks
for joining us Doug hey thank you Zoe
and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week but a quick heads up our
special weekly series on AI artificially
minded is coming soon we'll tackle some
of the big questions around generative
Ai and how it's already affecting life
work and business in surprising ways you
can catch artificially minded every
Monday in April starting April 3rd and
there's still time to send us your
questions for the series leave us a
voicemail at
415-439-6482 or email us a voice
recording to tnb wsj.com we look forward
to hearing from you
tnb's producer is Julie Chang we had
production assistants from Zoe Culkin
our supervising producer is Melanie Roy
and our executive producer is Chris
sinsley I'm your host Zoe Thomas thanks
for listening and have a great weekend
[Music]